the golden knights are back on home ice
facing the colorado avalanche for the
second of four games in a week-long
series
sports director chris matthews joining
us now live from t-mobile arena with
more
on the night's preparations hi there
chris
how you doing guys i'll tell you what
normally this place would be absolutely
packed right with fans but
you got two of the top teams in the west
playing tonight as you mentioned vegas
home with the colorado avalanche
now these are the two of the top four
teams in the west division so you know
at the end of the season
they'll be right in the mix for a
playoff spot it's going to be exciting
when it comes down it gets tense toward
the end of the
end of the season here but right now
everybody's talking about marc-andre
fleury
and his play and the guy's been
absolutely phenomenal
the flowers been playing really well
making his fifth straight start
there isn't a better goalie in the
league right now playing uh with uh
stopping 100 of his last 106 shots
he's faced with a 9.34 percentage
and that one shutout the guy's really
playing well in fact he was named the
nhl second star
player of the week with his terrific
play in net kind takes you back to his
days in 2017 dozen of making all sorts
of stops
he's been on fire and thus the golden
knights have the best mark in the west
so we know we knew if i was one of the
best going in the league if not the best
so um
i think he still got it um everyone was
doubting him
a little bit but i think he's still got
him he's been showing it he plays uh he
plays hard he practice really hard
every day gets better so i think it's
good for us
all right so after tonight the knights
and abs meet two more times after
saturday's unique game
the outdoor game up there in tahoe then
they're back in denver on monday
vegas will be back home on march 1st to
meet minnesota the wild come rolling in
here
and we should be looking for fans in the
stands at that time
we're pretty excited about that outdoor
game it's going to be vegas and the
avalanche up in south tahoe
they're going to be playing on a golf
course fairway so the rink is about done
in fact tonight
they're actually striping the ice up
there in tahoe so we'll have
much more in that an exciting time we'll
be up in tahoe with the golden knights
as they take on the avalanche we'll have
much more for you in fact we're going to
meet with a guy named derrick king
who is in charge of all the facilities
for that at the rink up there in tao
you'll hear what he has to say and peter
deboer how excited they are for that
event we'll have much more come
for you coming up at six o'clock
reporting from live outside toshiba
plaza chris matthews
8 sports now thanks chris that's going
to be gorgeous setting up there on the
water in lake tahoe